on the issue of property regimes for
international couples the Netherlands
presidency is very pleased that the
council decided on enhanced cooperation
18 member state reached an general
approach today on to regulations aimed
at determining the rules applicable to
property regimes for married couples or
registered partners in cross-border
situations the regulations aimed to
determine which court will have
jurisdiction for and which law will be
applicable to matters of matrimonial
property regimes and the property
consequences of registered partnerships
they will establish clear rules on
applicable law in case of divorce or
death bringing more legal certainty and
putting an end to parallel and possibly
conflicting proceedings in various
Member States today we also made it
would progress on the future European
prosecutor's office the negotiations
have been on what our work is beginning
to bear fruit and we have almost
finished the technical work on the text
and I am convinced that by the end of
this year we can reach an agreement but
sill there is a lot of work ahead of us
we've made important steps with the
counterterrorism group that involves
three aspects one is there's a platform
of intelligence officers of all the 30
participating countries that meet
basically all the time second there is a
database created in which all
participating countries put the
information they have on foreign
fighters third the counterterrorism
group has been embedded in the
environment of all the other
institutions but a decision taken today
to have the CTG present as a guest in
every meeting of the justice and Home
Affairs or whenever terrorism is on the
agenda today's good news is the
council's common approach on the
firearms directly we want to tighten our
rules and live as little as space as
possible
for exception that criminals can exploit
we agree that we need to act along the
whole route this means that we need to
address the root causes of people
leaving which is mainly for economic
reasons and that members say it should
register migrants there where they enter
Europe and we cannot waive migrants
migrants through to our neighbors most
importantly we need to effectively
return people to their home country when
they're not entitled to refugee status
and also to prevent people from leaving
in the first place is now time to
drastically increase the settlement from
Turkey as well as the locations from
Greece and Italy finally we exchange the
views on the Commission's visa
liberalisation proposal for Georgia
Ukraine Kosovo and Turk the Commission
has been very clear in its
recommendations I hope that progress in
the council and Parliament will come
soon thank you